nous allons revoir en chiffres si vous
le voulez bien l'évolution des
différentes prestations depuis cinq ans
sur ce petit commentaire que nous a fait
pour nous jean louis les scènes les plus
défavorisés des français 7e que le
président de la république le 8 août
dernier avait demandé au gouvernement
d'aider particulièrement à la rentrée
les mesures annoncées ce matin intérêts
seront donc d'abord les personnes âgées
titulaires du minimum vieillesse elles
sont en france deux millions deux cent
mille en cinq ans depuis le 1er janvier
1974 ce minimum vieillesse touché par
l'intermédiaire du fonds national de
solidarité
ce minimum a pour le moment augmenté de
165 % ensuite ces mesures bénéficieront
aux familles la dotation spéciale
affectés pour cette rentrée aux familles
répondant à certains critères notamment
des critères de revenus cette dotation
viendra s'ajouter aux augmentations de
prestations familiales depuis cinq ans
ses prestations ont déjà connu une
hausse de 71,6 pour ça bien sûr il est
nécessaire de rapprocher ces chiffres de
l'augmentation du coût de la vie durant
la même période + 61,3 % depuis 74
parallèlement le salaire minimum le smic
qui atteindra à partir du 1er septembre
prochain 12 francs 42 par heure or à lui
connu une hausse de 128 % en cinq ans
les mesures annoncées aujourd'hui en
conseil des ministres ne font donc
qu'amplifier le processus engagé il ya
cinq ans pour aider les personnes les
plus modestes à atténuer les retombées
d'une hausse rapide du coût de la vie à
noter enfin que ces mesures ne
constituent pas à proprement parler une
augmentation des prestations mais sont
des primes exceptionnelles l'enveloppent
de la dépense réalisé grèvera le budget
de 2 milliards de francs environ